In Ramadan, mashallah, a lot of people
coming to the mid to pray in the mid.
So, we should not be the slaves of
Ramadan. We should be st of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala.
And subhan Allah. Uh I know there's some
people like they have night shift, they
cannot make it would have other excuses,
legit excuses, but we should try our
best to start our day
with subh. Imagine you starting your day
praying f prayer in the masjid. Subhan
Allah. And uh you know
something like today it was just like
four of us praying prayer. Four of us
literally and there's a brother he
wanted he was showing his masjid. There
was only one one row and he put picture
of the mud protesting thousands of
people protesting pray one row. Some
hypocrites they hate when you speak like
this. Why? because we expose them. Allah
has laid down sunnah in his creation
that is impossible for Allah's victory
to come full victory that the full
victory until establish Allah's dean
Allah will never change state of the
people until they change themselves when
Allah gave victory the Sahabah they were
not protesting day and night and first
prayer no one in the masjid what they
were doing making sure to establish the
deen within themselves and outside in
reality
that Allah gave them victory but that's
why we have we have an established
ourselves let alone establishing upon
other people so we have to to understand
my dear brothers may bless you all we
have to do
jihad like one guy he said you want to
carry a car but you cannot even carry a
blanket you cannot even remove the
blanket from yourself to come pray a
prayer subhan allah you know Allah abbar
this of Allahhaala
But what what's happening to what's
happening to us? Even the enemies of
Islam have noticed we are the easiest
people to be deceived by slogans. We are
easy to be deceived by slogans. Now if
you go and say like for example now
people are misusing and abusing the
issue of
philine. Like one of the bit exposed he
was saying what is the Muslims? Why not
have philistine? He start doing dancing
like a woman. This person has been
exposed dancing like a woman.
Allah well
acquainted you like it or not. Of course
the will hate it. But people
of they understand
it look the stories of the pro the
prophets and messages of the Quran
Misallamatam. Subhan Allah. That doesn't
mean you cannot defend yourself.